let's go ahead and get started on this
very clicks ad title that drew a pretty
big crowd so you know is spark still
relevant how many of you are hoping that
I'm gonna say no just a quick show of
hands all right
so and and yes why are the rest of you
here no it's fine I'm so so about me I
am currently a Solutions Architect at
anaconda that means that I talk to most
of our large customers about problems
that they're having in this space how we
how our enterprise product can you know
fit inside of their infrastructure which
is usually enterprise how many here have
done anything in the enterprise
involving like IT and InfoSec and
ticketing systems and yeah ok so like
some people here are fully aware of that
pain so you know we try and help our
customers navigate through that
minefield I'm also a part of the Condor
for its core team before that I worked
in ad tech on a Hadoop platform team
that was you know a fun job but you know
it's ad tech so it's got its downsides
before that I wrote scientific software
at Brookhaven before that I finished a
PhD in chemistry which is not at all
relevant for anything that I do today so
should you go to grad school the answer
is probably not so you know just keep
that in mind so my original talk plan
was to do a bake-off gang task sparking
Rapids you know we have this great
downloads data set internally at
anaconda with billions of rows you know
basically compare desks Park and Rapids
through kind of an end-to-end lifecycle
of you know the kinds of problems that
we solve in the space that was a little
ambitious I didn't really really think
through how how much infrastructure I
was going to need to actually do a
proper bake-off so I'm on a week ago
after I'd spent about a week and a half
fighting with parquet formats I'm like
I'm gonna pivot this talk so we're not
we're not actually doing that this would
be great to do at some point it would
also be great as a blog post so
hopefully I'll have some time and space
to get that done I also came to the
realization that I'm not
really gonna move the needle with like
an n plus one talk on wide ask is
functionally equivalent to spark or like
wide ask is better or faster or why
rapids as you know orders of magnitude
faster than both of those because GPUs
there are tons of those out there
already so you know feel free to laugh
at me about you know how how ambitious
that was so this talk instead is not as
far as to relevant the answer is yes so
for those of you that wanted me to you
know dump on spark you know you are
welcome to leave I will not be offended
that is now this talk is so instead I'm
gonna try and answer the question of why
our Enterprise is still choosing spark
right I mean we're all I mean many of us
here no task or Rapids or this ecosystem
and really wish that we could use it in
our day-to-day jobs instead of spark but
for you know for reasons that hopefully
will become clear throughout this talk
we're gonna look at why that's not the
case right now so what is this about a
brief overview like you know what what
do businesses care about right these are
kind of my experiences from talking to
our anaconda enterprise customers you
know from talking with other people in
this space as well I'm gonna do a you
know hopefully a reasonably thorough job
of comparing these different ecosystems
in terms of different functionalities
also please feel free to come find me
and I will you know happily give you
this this talk deck so if you like if
you're taking pictures you know please
feel free but you know we'll we'll
figure out a way to get you the talk
slides so comparing the ecosystems
across the number of metrics kind of
just an example like you know PowerPoint
version of what an implementation would
look like and then kind of some some
thoughts at the end about how to
actually drive adoption into the
enterprise's of these technologies so
first off who he knows what spark is all
right to ask and Rapids okay so real
quick cuz that wasn't everybody in the
room spark you have distributed data
frames on the JVM on the CPU
- you have just super data frames on CPU
and Python and Rapids is distributed
data frames and Python on the GPU in
very short there are many so I know that
tom is here on the desk team I know that
keith is here from Rapid so if you want
you know more info about that then I
would talk to them so what a business is
care about risk that's that's kind of it
that's like the big thing that
businesses are gonna be focused on and
everything else in this talk really kind
of centers around risk and managing it
and minimizing it and understanding it
and quantifying it in a different ways
that you can think about risk you've got
the notion of time to value it right
which is how fast am I gonna start
seeing this affect my bottom line right
how how much is this solution gonna cost
me to own right and you can get answers
to that with spark pretty easily there's
a there's an ocean of people that you
can go to for help here I think there's
one company that you can go to with this
for desk and that's come on-site and
they're brand new right like there's not
like if you look at this ecosystem
there's not as much available in the
desk space to service these kinds of
enterprise needs and certainly not in
Rapids because they're brand new I mean
you know they're doing a fantastic job
but they're still brand new right I mean
it's it's not like this is anything
unique to desk this is just what happens
with a brand new project SLA is in
support right who are you gonna call at
9:00 p.m. on a Tuesday when your
infrastructure falls over right you're
not gonna go post to the desk issue
tracker and say help well I mean you
probably are now because you can't go
pay anybody for this same thing with the
support right who were you gonna go when
you you know when task is almost the
right choice but you need a new feature
right you're not I don't know welcome
on-site right but like there is not a
notion of these consultancies like there
is with SPARC and if you are in that
space please come talk to me because it
would be very useful for us at anaconda
to have a stable of these kinds of
companies and people that we can you
know talk to and work with to help our
clients do better sales pitch done
all right so you know some examples of
like custom solutions that you would
want to implement right like you've got
desk and Rapids how do I bring that into
my existing entry right how do i hook it
into my existing off right so talking to
some people here they've they've told me
about their horrible homegrown all
systems right and these are not you know
small companies these are fortune 50
companies that have for whatever reason
decided to write their own off right
that's not gonna plug in easily so you
know you would need to pay somebody for
help with that you know connecting to a
database connection to your specific
type of networks file storage you know
how do you how do I push a desk job into
production with my enterprise scheduler
it's like these are the things that
businesses care about you know and they
will happily pay people to to build out
custom pipelines for data engineering or
the machine learning finally training
right who are you gonna pay to get these
people up to speed right so you know
those of us that are in this room
already on that path of you know
becoming experts on tasks and Rapids but
there are a lot of people in the
enterprise that are not in this room
right now and you know maybe each of you
will go back and train the people around
you but realistically to make a dent in
the SPARC adoption inside of the
enterprise you need people that can go
and train so just in summary those five
things you will see this slide again I'm
not going to read a slide to you because
that's awful okay so ecosystems so this
is where we're gonna look at these
different products in terms of differ
not products these these different
ecosystems in terms of metrics that I
thought were relevant so first off we've
got the maturity of the project so this
one's pretty straightforward apache
spark has been around I think let's say
yeah so spark is about nine and a half
so it's been around for a while
I think dass was approaching its fifth
birthday Rapids I thought was a couple
years old at Keith's today told me it
was a little over a year so somewhere in
the one to two years so the syntax here
like yeah cool okay the you know yellow
warning sign is like you should you know
dig into this a little bit you'll see a
red X on the next slide that's like
definitely like warning here so job
scheduling so if you've got jobs that
have to run if you're if you want to
submit jobs to production how do those
work spark has the you know yarn for for
all of its flaws and for all of the
people that hate yarn it still does a
pretty darn good job of getting things
done in a constraint system so you know
if you're on if you've got an on-prem
cluster and you've got limited compute
capacity there right like you're going
to have more people trying to use it
then you have capacity for and yarn does
it quite it yarn does a good job there
Rapids I think this after some
conversations this shouldn't be a red X
because Rapids in many ways will fall
back on whatever tasks can do so the
desk ecosystem will be dependent on its
back-end so if you run tasks on yarn
then it's the same story of SPARC if you
run tasks on kubernetes and again please
you know come up to me afterwards and
tell me that I'm an idiot because you
know there's this obvious thing that I
should be aware of but from my
understanding kubernetes doesn't have
the same type of kind of queueing
mechanisms that yarn does and you've got
the different HPC backends so slurm at
PBS that I am completely unfamiliar with
but they're there as well so also to
keep in mind the difference between
on-prem and cloud right so if you're on
the cloud then none of this really
matters right the metric is how much
you're gonna spend not like how much
you've already got in place so the
notion of kind of queueing in the cloud
is a far less relevant because you know
you just spin up your elastic coo-coo
communities cluster and you know you
don't have a queue but it might cost a
lot so you've got workflow scheduling
right so SPARC you've got easy and as
Caban I think Azkaban was out of
LinkedIn is that right maybe anyways
with Rapids and - you've got tools like
airflo and Luigi I think so show of
hands who knows what airflow is okay
cool
Luigi prefect dot IO much less okay so
prefect dot IO is a company in this
space that will sell you so they have a
product that's airflow + desk it's you
know and and an interesting option and
and does help kind of my narrative here
around like growing growing this
ecosystem is going to require more
companies in this space that are trying
to support these products that are
seeing the enterprise problems that are
building tools in the open source space
that will help drive more adoption so I
mean realistically there's good options
on both sides here so with scalability
single node versus distributed right
with spark so does anybody here actually
you spark and local mode ok I really
want to talk to you about why not not
only because I think you're like you're
doing anything wrong I'm just curious
because I don't run across people that
frequently that you spark in local mode
so you know maybe that was a bit you
know unnecessarily harsh on technically
yes but you know I have no problem being
wrong about any of this
so with Rapids you've got single node
performance that's amazing because
you're you're and you know on the GPU
and we've all heard how GPU makes
everything a lot faster and asked has a
great single node story it's very easy
to use it gives you the api's that
you're used to do be did mode spark
versus desk that's you know it's a
fairly straightforward story and Rapids
distributed the only reason that's kind
of like like yes ish is because I don't
think that they've got the full kind of
stable of distributed algorithms that
things like desk and sparked it yet but
again I could also be very wrong about
that also I don't know how common
distributed GPU clusters are yet
so it's not to say that like you know
you can't build one and it's it's not to
say that a video won't happily sell you
one but I just don't know kind of in
terms of finding people that you could
pay to manage it I think that would all
also be hard
alright so algorithm was right we've got
kind of graph algorithms machine
learning and deep learning again there
are good choices for everything here the
only reason why the machine learning
side with spark here is uh yellow I
don't know how many people would
voluntarily pick ml lib oversight can't
learn I think that my my kind of you
know completely unscientific poll of
people that I've talked to in the space
would much prefer the scikit-learn API
and kind of the rich ecosystem of
algorithms that scikit-learn will
provide over Anna Lib and sport does
have X G booster a but you also have
extra boost available and ask and I
think there's a CUDA accelerated version
of that as well admittedly I don't know
the deep learning story on spark so you
know if there is a very good very
compelling deep deep learning story
there great you know come come come talk
to me again tell me why I'm and and
idiot up here totally fine with that
yeah you know data visualization this is
where like this is really the spot that
I think spark is missing a big chunk of
the ecosystem I mean I don't again I
don't think that there's a rich
ecosystem like there is in the Python
world for visualizing with spark I mean
you know maybe data bricks has a product
that would be fantastic for this I I
just don't know I I haven't encountered
anybody who does work in spark and then
knows how to visualize their 100 million
or billion row data frame I I personally
know how to do that and Rapids a desk
you you can use data shader and ask to
you know spend this up and it and it
works great you can build an an
interactive dashboard that can serve 100
million rows of data and you know it can
down sample it and real
time with you know you can zoom in and
zoom out and change filters and all that
it's quite nice in terms of a data
framing API right they've all got this
the biggest hole in the dasi ecosystem
right now is the lack of sequel right
there's no sequel compiler and tasks and
Rapids has there's a product in the
rapid space called blazing sequel that
gives you this type of an interface so
why do we care about sequel right I mean
it's what 2019 so according to sack
overflow professional developers still
use sequel far more than they would use
Python I also like to take a little jab
at our in Scala here but it's fine it's
fine but but seriously so sequel is
where you know the kind of people that
we will label is less technical right
the business analysts the marketing
scientists but those are the people that
actually know how the business is run
they are incredibly valuable without
those people like your [ __ ] you're
gonna have a much less a much less
effective business and generally
speaking they're all or many of them are
quite comfortable in sequel so things
like spark C cool things like blazing
sequel give your marketing science team
your business analysts access to your
you know petabytes of data that are
locked away I think that's a big gap in
the desk ecosystem currently regarding
data access right with spark you know
you've got access to HDFS s3 hive flat
files etc pythons got a much richer data
data access story you can access
everything that you can with spark
you know it's probably not as performant
but it doesn't have to be yeah so
streaming wise again this is not
necessarily so much is like which of
these streaming libraries is better it's
more just that they're all there this is
a this is a comparison of ecosystem
functionality more so than it is like
a bake-off between like oh you know -
plus dreams is so much better than spark
streaming or that's not what this is
like the capability is there and also
this is you know again I have not spent
enough time in the the streaming world
so this is a real dense slide but this
is effectively a summary of everything
that I just said and I will show I will
have this slide up at the very end for
questions as well so this is not the
last time that you have an opportunity
to take a picture of the slide but you
know the the important takeaway here is
the trend right for the most part they
all have functionality across this this
slice of the ecosystem right there's not
one perfect tool here
I mean you could almost certainly use
any of these independently in terms of
their technical feasibility right I mean
in very specific circumstances maybe you
want more than one of them in the long
term again the biggest holes here are
the the spark ecosystem I think is
lacking a little in the kind of machine
learning deep learning visualization
space compared to the Python space and
of course you know the big red X on task
is a proper sequel engine alright so
time check we're at 18 minutes okay cool
so you know real quick let's start
talking about some of the architecture
some of the infrastructure like the ways
that you would actually start to stand
up some of these things will grow in
complexity we're gonna start with Rapids
right this is a very easy to understand
slide you go by a server from Nvidia and
you can use Rapids it's very easy you
know you've got the Python interfaces to
your your data you certainly can do
shared infrastructure and have multiple
users on a single GPU this is this is
not in any way saying like this is the
perfect architecture I don't work of
Nvidia I have no idea this is the
perfect way to get this this up and
running but in terms of like ease of use
you know in terms of minimizing the
infrastructure costs here you probably
just want to give
data scientists their own server just
four starts then you know people can
work by themselves and get off to the
races a really good way to run desk
right now is desk on kubernetes it's
very simple weave and anaconda this year
has been working on a project called
bass gateway happy to talk more about
that later or if there's time at the end
I can certainly come back to it but
basically you know the idea here is that
if you have kubernetes already or if you
want to run on the cloud you can spin up
desk gateway you you Hjelm install it
you you can help install it into an auto
scaling kubernetes cluster it works with
whatever auth you you you haven't place
already users will connect to desk
gateway desk game it will spin up a desk
cluster on kubernetes desk a proxy the
scheduler back to the user and of a
proxy the desk dashboard as well so you
can have everything behind a committees
zone and then still you would run the
desk client locally to wherever these
users are and you've got full access to
whatever data you have and also worth
mentioning is that and the Rapids
project can also or the Rapids the
ecosystem will also work well it will
work the same way
eventually we need to add support and
desk gateway to run desk cuda workers
but the infrastructure would
theoretically be the same air spark own
yarn is a much harder diagram to
actually like put up on a screen there's
a lot there but in terms of getting you
know being useful and getting work done
right you can either SSH into an edge
node and run SPARC shell or PI spark or
install you know a duper notebook and
port forward that you know I know that
you three there in the second row that I
worked with at max point have all done
this so you can use something called
Libby which is a server that you run on
the edge node it it exposes interactive
spark over HTTP you can use a project
and the
ecosystem called spark magic to connect
to Livi and run interactive spark from
wherever right you've got the sequel
interface with hive and spark sequel
you've got scripting with pig you know
Hadoop yarn spark okay so so kind of
with that out of the way how do we start
getting PI data how do we start getting
desk and Rapids into the enterprise like
how do we penetrate that space and you
know get it to the level of prominence
that spark has have I happened to find
this really good quote from Shane when I
was doing a bit of research for this
talk and I really like it because it's
basically the same point that I'm trying
to make but it's not from me you know so
clearly at least one other person has
has the the same thought here so I will
read it because it's interesting it's
hard to get organizational buy-in to
adopt an open-source technology without
vendors support and enterprise SLA s so
how many people in this room have fought
the same battle one to you know a
handful 10 20 and I talking to a
customer about four months ago they said
this to me I didn't really know what to
say because I was taken aback right like
they're not all in on task because what
if anaconda isn't around in a few years
and I was like but it's but there's more
to it than anaconda right like there's
Nvidia's contributing and there are
folks well those those are the two big
ones and Kalan side as well you know and
and and there's you know a horde of kind
of smaller in individual contributors
but like it definitely plays to the same
point about who were they supposed to
call for help who are they're supposed
to pay for implementation services like
how is this supposed to work at the
enterprise scale so you know I thought
it was relevant enough here so again as
promised a a reminder of my thesis here
these are the things that enterprises
are going to care about these are the
things that enterprises do care about
looking around for phones up I got to
all right so right we're not missing
features all right this is this this
isn't a lack of features in Basque right
think about Jupiter hub right I mean
it's not like Jupiter hub isn't I mean
chubarov is everywhere but it but it's
not it's not seeing more adoption
because it lacks features right it's
what we need to see Jupiter hub you know
dominate the landscape our consultancies
around it our people that are solving
these enterprise problems around these
these open source projects so here's
another really fun controversial slide
that you know I'm sure I'll get a lot of
flack for I'm totally fine with that you
know the the the whole point here is to
spark a conversation right for all of
these right spark is green across the
bowl blue across the board right I don't
really even know how you would quantify
the risk of adopting Rapids or adopting
tasks inside of your enterprise
infrastructure I don't know right I mean
I think that there's a real big need in
this space for people that really stand
up and proclaim like you know I'm an
expert in desk like pay me and I will
help you figure out you know how to
adopt ask inside of your enterprise in
terms of institutional support or a desk
has you know at least three companies
behind it right now we've got anaconda
and Quan site and Nvidia in terms of
institutional support for Rapids I think
that's pretty much Nvidia at this point
again you know I'm tell me that I'm
wrong there right but in terms of the
risk right if you only have one company
behind this open-source ecosystem that
you're building your business on you
know if they decide that they don't want
to you know build Rapids anymore then
you know risk right same story with
consulting and implementation services I
I don't know of anybody right now that
you could go and pay for support and
implementation on in the rapids
ecosystem but again I don't know that I
would expect either because right there
like one to two years old Ford asked
again I know
kuan site I don't know of anybody else
again if you are that person come and
talk to me training wise I know that you
can get training support for desk and
and I'm just ignoring SPARC because you
can get these things from an ocean of
consultancies or cut area or data breaks
or EMR or you know there's a lot of ways
in which you can get that training
services I'm pretty sure you could go to
Quan side to get training on rapids yeah
yes okay Thank You Anthony and then kind
of the same thing with a risk I don't
really know how to quantify the time to
value and total cost of ownership for
tools like - Kent Rapids uh it's a good
quick look at my presenting news yeah ok
all right so what do we do well for
starters you could build a proper sequel
engine a proper sequel compiler and desk
that'll that'll that'll help you on
board more job titles to the desk
ecosystem that gets you the business
analyst the marketing scientist business
intelligence etcetera you know the
people again actually know how your your
business works
you can sort a product company in this
space to productize something around
desk or Rapids that'll that'll reach
more enterprises you can start a
consulting company around task or Rapids
although it's probably a little early
for Rapids that'll help to make it
sticky in these enterprises that want to
use desk but need help so for those of
you in the enterprise right for the
actual practitioners here like what can
you do with these ecosystems how should
you think about using them and adopting
them so the first question is do you
already have SPARC right and if you have
SPARC great like you you you have a tool
that you can use if you want to use desk
- gateway works with SPARC right there's
there's a number of projects in the desk
ecosystem that are specifically designed
to work with spark on on yarn
there's desk yarn there's desk gateway
that you can install alongside your
Hadoop cluster where a desk gateway will
then talk to yarn and provision yarn
containers
and run desk basket workers inside of
those yarn containers so you get to use
desk without needing any new adoption of
any new infrastructure and if you don't
have spark already then you know you
should probably think long and hard
about adopting it it's a it's a very
complex to stack question - do you have
kubernetes if you do great helm
installed desk gateway you'll probably
need to work with your IT teams and your
info SEC teams but at least you don't
need to try and argue that you need new
infrastructure
do you have GPUs again if you do awesome
right you know you can Conda installed
desk or Rapids and just start playing
around with it and figure out if it
solves the use case and in it and if it
does then you've got some more ammo to
go say look we need to invest more in
this it solves these kinds of problems
and the obvious question is do you have
cloud access and if you do great you
know you can use desk on an auto scaling
cute kubernetes cluster you can try
Rapids on some GPU instances very low
risk here but you still are also really
gonna need the need to make the case
about why you should be adopting tasks
why should be adopting Rapids and it's
not it's not gonna be the the easiest
thing in the world again because you
can't go pay somebody to help you make
that argument right there's there's no
support or I mean there's open-source
support but you can't the enterprise
need for support isn't there uh ok cool
so in summary right we've got I mean
desk and Rapids are basically at
ecosystem feature parity with SPARC the
reasons why desk and Rapids and SPARC or
desk and Rapids are not seeing the same
adoption as spark as is not due to
features you know we need companies in
this space and you can also start using
these tools so came in a lot under what
I thought I was going to so thank you
for listening
[Applause]
icebox
all right so unfortunately I find four
questions in this very controversial
topic so here we go yeah I thought it
was a great talk
it's just a question how much do you
think the adoption of spark was driven
by offerings by the major cloud
providers
I mean Amazon picked it up in like 2015
and that's like what four years after
after it was released by Berkeley would
that mean that like desk and Rapids
would be at least like four years out
before you would see major cloud
adoption well I mean so that's a that's
a good question
I I don't have a good answer for you I
mean I like I think that Basques is I
think that desk is kind of approaching
that spot where we can start to expect
to see oh good Anthony great where we
can start to see some some cloud
companies start some like bask as a
service type companies I in fact Hugo
has one hugo's you know goal here is to
be data bricks for desk as I will say
but you know you should talk to him
because it's it's okay well there you go
yeah so data bricks for desk right here
so I would expect these to start to to
show up for desk certainly and like
honestly I ate I think the cloud
landscape was 2015 is very different
from the cloud landscape of 2019 so
we'll see all right what you got Anthony
all right um hi Eric so it occurs to me
that you're overloading the term
ecosystem here to mean both corporate
ecosystem and and community ecosystem
and those it seemed it seems like those
the point of this talk is to try to
resolve some of those discrepancies and
maybe help bring an open-source
ecosystem into kind of just to be able
to serve the needs of these corporate
ecosystems are there resources available
that help like inform and educate us all
about how that happens and and and help
resolve those two two ecosystems
that's a very good question which I
suspected look at it I don't know I mean
it like it takes like it takes you know
people that are kind of that are
bridging that that gap that are both
involved in open source but are also in
the enterprise and kind of trying to
drive these kinds of problems and like
and I solve these kinds of problems you
know that sounds like a great
opportunity to write some interesting
blog posts but in terms of like you know
broader resources and tools I yeah open
to ideas
Thanks oh we have a time for one more
question all right cool
well thanks everybody thank you
[Applause]